[Door opening]
- I know what the f--k I'm doing.
I'm allowed to be here.
- There's vomit on your sweater already?
- Little Caesars hot and ready.
- Stop rapping about vomit. We're up next.
- ♪♪♪ Oh boy, looks like you've been slain
by my No. 1 guy with a high ankle sprain! ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- [Together:] Good game. Good game.
- There's nothing young white coaches love more than "8 Mile."
- NFC, let's get ready for the final battle.
- ♪♪♪ Lance, Jimmy G., gave the rock to Purdy.
Mr. Irrelevant and Imma still hang 30. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- ♪♪♪ You had four QBs, whoops now you've got none.
Oh, what an offensive GENIUS, another Deebo run. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- ♪♪♪ Got big dreams, and think you're getting closer.
What's that? DPOY Nick Bosa. ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- You said Toby Keith was performing.
- ♪♪♪ Hate to pan the man, but he's just a nepo baby.
Hey Shanahan, how many snubs you get from Brady? ♪♪♪
- [Crowd:] Oooh!
- All right, playas.
Winner is decided by whoever gets the loudest.
- How does that make sense?
- Aaaah. LOUD SCREAMING.
- ♪♪♪ Nicky Sirianni says Nicky Sayonara.
31-7 is the final score-a.
Fly Eagles fly, bye Niners byeeee. ♪♪♪
[Cheering]
- Philly wins!
[Knocking]
Oh, no, the stripes are here! Run!
[Whistles]
- Everybody else got dues to pay.
Little Zac got a gig 'cause he met McVay.
Hamburger eats, giant playsheets,
Ya gonna get beat, I got Reid receipts!
- Your weak-ass rhymes don't affect me.
Could've been friends, you're my Bienemy.
Joe Cool in the pocket making you pay,
Got all the homies back in Cincy yellin':
Oh, Who Dey?!